oh hi we're down here at Game Developers
Conference you know my favorite part of
GDC is the independent Games Festival we
can take a look at some of the year's
best games made by small teams students
and guys in their parents basements
oh hi everybody we are here with two
jeev who is one of the programmers on
the student showcase Award winner at the
independent Games Festival called tag
the power of paint to jeev tell me tell
me about tag the power of paint is a
first-person puzzle platformer all about
painting you have different colors of
paint and each color gives you a
different abilities Green lets you jump
red gives you a speed boost and blue
lets you stick up walls and ceilings and
stuff like that you use the different
colors to traverse the levels solve the
puzzles and get to the goal and then get
to the next level and do it again with
more complex puzzles it's not like if
you got to run up a wall really fast you
might put some blue on the wall but then
put some red underneath it so you get
the speed boost and the blue right right
yeah you can you can combine the
different colors in different ways so
you can also do like a like a long strip
of red followed by some green so you get
a really long jump and you can pass like
you cross like really big gaps in the
levels and stuff like that and we can
download this for free right now for
free from our website the power of paint
com we are here with Desmond Wong of the
Singapore MIT game lab and Desmond's
Barrow in this particular market place
of the independent Games Festival is
carnival show time Desmond once you tell
us what turn email show time is so
basically you place a circus acrobat and
you're supposed to fling yourself
through this performance to reach the
top so you get a go through lots of like
cool stuff like Rockets flaming hoops
like electric balls or fiery hazardous
yeah those cool stuff yeah and what was
your role on the game I was a Lee artist
and designer for this game yeah so I did
most of the graphical assets and level
designs yeah and if people want to play
carnival show time can they yeah of
course I mean you guys could go on the
Xbox Live the community games and play
this game for just a small price of 5
USD just just five US dollars exactly
Desmond I love this game congratulations
thanks a lot one of the more
experimental games here at the
independent Games Festival is the
Innovation Award nominee called the
Graveyard developed by a group called
tale of tales the graveyard is a very
short very small game in which what you
do is you walk a tiny little old lady up
to a
in a cemetery than you sit down and a
song plays about all the loved ones that
she's lost as the camera pans over the
graves and then sometimes but not always
the little old lady dies on the bench
sometimes you can pick her up and walk
her out of the graveyard
the graveyard is a really interesting
experiment with you know death and video
games and you know can it emotionally
affect you and it's really it's really
for you to sort of read into it what you
want to read into it it didn't win the
Innovation Award but it is definitely
innovative and tale of tales actually
has a new game out called the path it's
a sort of a fractured fairy tale look at
the Little Red Riding Hood story told
six times over using different
characters that walk through the woods
to Grandma's house and on the way have
an encounter with the big bad wolf in a
variety of different metaphorical sort
of forms you can download them both
right now and I encourage you to go and
check them out they're a really
interesting look at how video games can
be quite different than what you'd
expect we are here with Daniel Tabar who
actually won two awards last night the
independent Games Festival Awards Daniel
why don't you tell us about your game
here well this is cortex Command the
premises that you're a brain that is
this embody that controls all these
other disposable expendable puppets that
you do your bidding basically for you
you can have a rivalry against any other
brain that also has their own group of
guys and you fight it out on this alien
planet and that's the story premise at
least so it seems like kind of a
combination of action and strategy yes
there's resources to be collected it's
gold in the ground they actually dig out
of the deformable terrain and you use it
to buy these expendable bodies these are
just brainless puppets so no one cries
if they die they as long as you can
afford them you know it's it's all good
well cortex to me looks really great
what are we gonna get to play it you can
play it right now it's available on our
website data realms comm or court vex
command comm you can actually although
it's not done yet
you can buy it early at a discount and
you will get all the updates and
you know future versions including the
final version without having to pay more
Daniel congratulations thank you I
appreciate it